come and get it all right Transformers
fans we just got a nice Feast of the
beasts with a brand new trailer look for
Transformers rise of the beasts and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down some of the Easter eggs
hidden details and things you missed in
it this won't be a scene by scene thing
of what happens in this trailer as it
does cover some of the same footage
we've seen of the other teasers and
trailers with a couple of different
shots and things that flesh out what's
happening therefore I kind of want to go
through all of the elements of this and
explain exactly what I think is
happening in this movie I also want to
talk about some of the plot leaks and
potential cameos teas teas that
apparently are going to feature in this
film but I'll be saving those for the
super duper crazy spoiler section at the
end of this video Transformers rise of
the Beast is being featured at cinemacon
today
tonight I'm gonna be honest I have no
idea when so hopefully at some point
we'll hear more about this movie which
will of course keep you updated on so
stay tuned to this channel make sure you
subscribe for that and also please hit
that thumbs up if you enjoy our
Transformers Breakdown so to grease the
wheels and get a moving rise of the
Beast will be apparently taking heavy
inspiration from one of my favorite 90s
animated shows beast wars and in this we
saw robotic descendants of the Autobots
and Decepticons properly named the
maximals and the Predacons get sucked
through a Time Warp essentially Crash
Landing to Earth millions of years
before civilization they then took the
form of animals because there was no
vehicles and aircrafts so it's just you
know beasts aka the name rise of the
beasts synopsis wise this takes place in
1994 being a very Loosely based foe
sequel to 2018's Bumblebee which was set
in 1987. however it doesn't appear
hailee steinfeld's Charlie character
will be making a return with word that
rise of the beasts is the first in a new
Transformers Trilogy so yay
unfortunately for all you bayham fans
out there this isn't going to connect to
the Michael Bay films that ruled the box
office of the late 2000s and 2010s but
with this taking place roughly 20 plus
years before there could be some Sly
connections and Easter eggs hint hint
we'll talk about them in the leaks
portion later but as far as Beast Wars
goes the main goal of that was to gather
the parts to fix their trans warp drive
and return back home to Cybertron which
seems to be the case here in Rise of the
beasts this is what causes the modern
day Autobots and Decepticons to team up
with their counterparts of the maximum
moles and Predacons who apparently have
already made a presence here on Earth
without them knowing all of this may
sound like gobblygoop to anyone unaware
of the Beast Wars series but let's break
it down the maximals are the equivalent
to Autobots mostly taking the form of
mammals birds or fish well Predacons are
essentially the Decepticons taking the
form of reptiles amphibians and insects
but yeah from the sounds of it the main
big Baddie isn't going to actually be
Megatron the Decepticons or even the
Predacons but rather an entirely
different faction of the terror cons
some of the lore around these dudes gets
a bit messy here or there but mainly
they are disbanded Decepticons that are
working directly with Galvatron in Rise
of the Beast though the leader of this
group is going to be Scourge voiced by
Peter Dinklage the Dink and his mission
is bringing Unicron to Earth to
transform the planet into a Cybertron
like Haven so evil robot dude wants to
take over our planet but he's way more
of a hunter tracker type essentially
keeping trophies from his kills by
fusing their insignias or the trophies
onto his own armor like a badass Rambo
robot so he's like a living Memorial to
the Havoc he's created just badass man
but reeling things back a bit in order
to get this Mega Showdown ready rise of
the Beast takes place you know like I
mentioned mainly in 90s Brooklyn New
York introducing Anthony Ramos's
character of Noah Diaz as the like Sam
Wick Wiki of this film said to be an
ex-military Electronics expert
supporting his family where he comes
across the autobot of Mirage now Mirage
has been a staple of the franchise you
know all the way back in the day this
time sporting the look of a silver blue
Porsche 964 and voiced by SNL Alum and
dude who is just getting all the ladies
Pete Davidson surprisingly I've seen
this a couple times but they've compared
him to the T-1000 from Terminator
because I'm assuming he'll be able to
morph his body into other cars I don't
know how hopefully no liquid cars please
do not do that on top of this rise of
the Beast is going to introduce Optimus
Prime voiced by Peter Cullen RC voiced
by Liza koshy who appears to be the
female Commando holding on to the brown
Volkswagen panel bus the Volkswagen
though is an Autobot scientist wheel
Jack voiced by Christo Fernandez and of
course our lovable yellow Corvette
bumblebee we also know Dominique
Fishback is going to be another leading
human character teaming up with Noah at
some point named Elena said to be like
an artifact researcher in New York uh or
the New York museum whose boss is like
taking credit for her work again I'm
sure her and Noah are going to team up
with the Autobots to help find the the
hidden trans warp keys that they need to
get back home and joining the Autobots
are the maximos the animal version of
the Autobots and going to include
Optimus primal a giant gorilla and great
pun name voiced by Ron Perlman air
raiser a peregrine falcon voiced by
Michelle Yao rhinox of course a
rhinoceros and one of my favorites from
the animated series who is the tech
expert for The maximo's Voice by David
sobolov along with chitar a cheetah who
is said to be the Rookie of the maximal
team now hardcore Beast Wars fans I'm
right there with you there is no word or
visuals yet of rat trap so fingers
crossed for that little dude to show up
but a few others rounding out the lineup
are the autobot Stratosphere voiced by
John DiMaggio who is essentially the
Autobots transport when they fly to what
looks like Machu Picchu and a character
named reek who we don't really know much
about right now aside from the character
being based on a mutual best friend of
director Caples who unfortunately passed
away prior to the filming in 2001. a
nice homage being played by Toby wigwe
who was supposed to join Noah and the
others on their Globe trotting Journey
some of the other terracons joining
their leader Scourge our freezer who is
a weapons artillery transport for the
group nightbird a female Terracon and
scourge's right-hand commander who
transforms into a Nissan Skyline I'm
telling you we're one step closer to a
fast and furious Transformers crossover
baby and the final two are Transit who
transforms into a school bus and battle
trap who transforms into an orange GM
top kick tow truck now plot wise rise of
the Beast continues the war between the
autobots and the Decepticons with the
arrival of the Maximus Predacons and
terracons changing the course of that
conflict whether that's for the better
or the worse we'll have to wait and see
but Noah and mirage's meeting in a
relationship is how the Autobots
essentially team up with the other human
characters and the trans warp keys are
the main mission of the movie with the
Autobots needing to decipher some sort
of ancient symbols like hieroglyphics
this is what brings Elena and sets the
group out to find the artifacts AKA The
Warp Keys the journey to what looks like
again Machu Picchu jungle environment
leads to them unearthing the maximals
who have been hiding on Earth for a
while without the Autobots knowing and
speaking of the Autobots they are
actually fairly new to Earth only
arriving you know at the end of
Bumblebee so Optimus Prime for example
isn't your stoic human loving hero robot
just yet instead he doesn't really
understand humans and what makes them so
special which will be an interesting
development for the leader of the
Autobots but with the discovery of the
maximals comes the Predacons and of
course the arrival of the terracons all
after the same end goal these big old
battle scenes are the Revival of the
ancient conflict that the three factions
of Transformers have been in for years
so I'm curious if we'll get a sneak peak
of this conflict before they venture to
Earth or only the battles after the fact
because some of these Landscapes after
everyone has teamed up look like more of
an alien planet-like than you know New
York or even the Lush environments of
Machu Picchu but hey I guess we'll see
with this taken place in 1994 we get a
shot of the New York City skyline and
the Twin Towers are still there because
uh yeah this is a pre-911 and it looks
like the maximals have been living in
Solace for some time in this jungle area
almost like an actual herd of animals
just blending into their surroundings
and it's a bit of a shocker that other
Autobots like Optimus Prime here not
just the maximos have arrived to Earth
so this unknown Alliance is definitely
gonna happen through this movie as we
see or get a better look of the
artifacts that are gonna be at play aka
the trans warp keys that they need to
piece together to actually either travel
back home or bring Unicron to Earth
which I'm gonna be honest Unicron here
looks hella weird but also kind of cool
inside of Mirage we get a nice flashback
of the times with the dash featuring
nothing but a 90s throwback with the
cassette player and Noah is rocking some
Early Air Jordans if you take a close
look and there's a way better look at a
whole Bevy of these Transformers that
are going to be in this movie including
scorponok or black zarok depending on
the version that you grew up with but
yeah like a load of these dudes I think
it's going to be like faceless monsters
or machines for them to face but looking
spot on with his animated counterpart
something else that is entirely new is
this mech suit Noah's given by Mirage
this is why he was compared to the
T-1000 because it gives part of his
spark to him creating a literal Mega Man
super suit to help him fight during the
end off everything as you can see him
holding on to Bumblebee's bumper during
this final battle so that pretty much
wraps up the trailer and I'm guessing
now we'll just get a bevy a whole bunch
of TV spots and variations of the
trailer that we've already seen with a
couple added things sprinkled in
hopefully no more of Optimus Prime
urging viewers for an intimate release
but I guess we'll see
let them come now there have been rumors
around where the plot of the movie goes
and how it potentially sets up a rise of
the Beast sequel so I want to jump Dive
Right In to the plot leak portions of
this video obviously heavy spoilers are
being thrown your way so if you don't
want to know anything more about this
upcoming Transformers movie then I
recommend you roll out now if you
enjoyed this video then please hit that
thumbs up button on your way out the
door and we'll see you next time take
care peace bye bye now bye bye
salutations okay all the Gobot fans gone
now cool so if you checked out our first
trailer breakdown then you know we
talked about the rumored plot of Rise of
the Beast which mainly focuses around
the autobots and maximos going head to
head with the terracons and Scourge who
is attempting to gather the trans warp
keys to bring Unicron to Earth on the
other hand the autobots and friends want
to use these trans warp keys to return
back home to Cybertron now one
interesting thing about Scourge is that
he is apparently going to be a
reprogrammed version of Optimus Prime
from the bay verse again only a rumor
but this would be on brand taking a page
from the 2001 animated Transformers
robots in Disguise series or scourge's
Origins turned out to be this while also
pain homage and kind of tying in you
know I guess the Transformers Universe
set of movies also from the leaked
Scourge toys his form seems to be very
Prime inspired just turning up that evil
dial to an 11. one of the biggest
heartbreaks is the exclusion the rumored
exclusion of any real Predacons I mean
scorponok like robots show up for a bit
but they are nameless kind of generic
machines for Scourge and or prime to
just get warmed up with so anyone hoping
for a proper uh Dinobot tarantulas or
even waspinator well uh maybe in a equal
but speaking of a sequel there's
supposed to be two different things that
could potentially spin off Noah and of
course the sequel the first being a
rumored scene of Noah being approached
and recruited by sector 7 towards the
very end of the film now sector 7 is
your stereotypical secret American
government agency which deals with
extraterrestrial technology and threats
this organization has been featured a
couple of times in the live action
movies specifically John Cena's
character from Bumblebee and with that
movie being set in 1987 and Rise of the
beasts taking place in 1994 this
recruitment seems on brand and is maybe
a way of bringing this organization into
more of a spotlight and with this
supposedly being the start of a new
Transformers Trilogy it's rumored that
the featured mid credit scene is teasing
the next film featuring Unicron which of
course was what the terracons were
rumored to be motivated into bringing to
Earth in Rise of the beasts
unfortunately time travel level which
played a huge prominent role in the
original Beast War series may be absent
from the entire plot which seems odd on
how to like really explain how the
maximals and Predacons got to Earth in
the first place but again take
everything with a grain of salt anyway
that is everything we know about
Transformers rise of the beasts so far
the good the bad the confusing on why
they are doing certain things but I'm
curious what are your thoughts of this
new Transformers movie does this sound
like more of the same or are you excited
to see Beast Wars lore finally hit the
big screen in live action and I'll let
you know we're currently running a
competition giving away three copies of
Ant-Man quantumania on the 15th of May
and all you got to do to get a chance of
likeness is like this video make sure to
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below on your thoughts of Rise
of beasts we picked the comments at
random at the end of every single month
and the winners of last month are on
screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out some of our other cool
videos over there great stuff we just
did a Flash trailer breakdown go and
watch that but with all of that out of
the way thank you so much for your
constant support I've been Jared I'll
see in the next one take care and roll
out